our health is the most precious thing we
have clean air and water are basic
things we need to be healthy yet each
year 300 000 people in Europe die yearly
because of bad air this means we are
losing a city bigger than Venice every
year
it's high time to improve our laws on
air and water and I'm very happy to
present you our proposals that will help
us tackle pollutants in air surface and
Wastewater based on the latest science
and technology we have for air we want
stricter air pollution limits better
monitoring and access to data and easier
ways for all of us to appeal to Justice
if we need to or what we want to tackle
more pollutants because their impact to
our health and environment is growing
Pharmaceuticals microplastics and
chemicals that stay long in the
environment for Wastewater we want to
reduce pollution from Urban sources
making one of the most energy consuming
sectors climate and energy neutral by
24.
it's our health insurance this is the
European green deal
[Music]